Madame la présidente
Monsieur le vice-président
Membres du Congrès
Distingués invités
Mes concitoyens américains
La Chine n’attend pas
pour restructurer son économie.
L'Allemagne n’attend pas.
L'Inde n’attend pas.
Ces pays ne restent pas inactifs.
Eh bien, je ne veux pas d’une deuxième place
pour les États-Unis.
Nous savons ce qu’il faut faire
pour être compétitifs aujourd'hui.
Nous devons dépasser le
reste du monde
en innovation, en éducation et en construction.
Nous pouvons nous contenter d'un pays
où de moins en moins de gens vivent bien
pendant que de plus en plus d'Américains
peinent à joindre les deux bouts.
Ou nous pouvons revenir à une économie
où tous ont une chance égale
où tout le monde contribue équitablement
et où tout le monde
joue selon les mêmes règles.
C'est la responsabilité de notre génération
de rallumer le véritable moteur de la
croissance économique des États-Unis :
une classe moyenne
croissante et prospère.
La dure réalité est que,
même en pleine reprise économique,
trop d'Américains travaillent comme des fous
juste pour survivre.
Et un trop grand nombre d’entre eux
sont encore au chômage.
Allons-nous accepter une économie
où seul un petit nombre réussit de façon spectaculaire
ou allons-nous plutôt nous engager dans la voie
d’une économie qui génère une augmentation
des revenus et des possibilités
pour tous ceux qui font des efforts?